good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your video on Friday and I thought
maybe today we could continue our
discussion of failure by turning to the
question of my new book so it's been
almost five years since my most recent
novel The Fault in Our Stars was
published why nothing new since then
well in my case because a very public
success happened to coincide with a
series of very private failures The
Fault in Our Stars was my fourth novel
but the experience of publishing it was
vastly different from everything that
came before like for context in the week
after it was published The Fault in Our
Stars sold more hard covers than my
three previous novels had ever sold
combined which to be clear was wonderful
news but at the same time I was hard at
work on this new book about teenage
identity thieves because you know that's
what I did after publishing a book I
wrote a new one no but it wasn't working
now partly the concept itself was flawed
I've always wanted to write a proper
thriller but I'm no good at writing any
of the proper thriller stuff you know
like I'm not great at action scenes or
knowing how guns work or plot but also I
started to feel this intense pressure
like people were watching over my
shoulder as I was writing by April of
2012 I ditched most of the identity
thieves story and reimagined it as a
story about two boys who find something
terrible while exploring storm drains in
their little hometown I wrote about 100
pages of that over the next few months
then none of it was ever very good
though meanwhile The Fault in Our Stars
continued to sell and in May of that
year I read an amazing screenplay
adaptation of the book at which point I
realized it might actually become a
movie and somewhere in that period my
job stopped being person who writes
books which is a present-tense job title
and became person who wrote that one
book which is a past tense job title
like I remember one night my best friend
Chris sang to me it must be weird
getting all this money for something you
did at Starbucks a couple years ago and
it was weird I was elated and grateful
that The Fault in Our Stars was reaching
so many readers but at the same time I
was terrified because I felt like I
could never follow it up by the time the
movie started shooting in the fall of
2013 I was failing to write a new book
this one about teenage con artists I
spent almost a year on that one before
eventually giving up I remember being in
a hotel room right after the movie came
out looking at these hundreds of pages
as I realized they would never be a book
and just sobbing now I want to be clear
here that these are high-class problems
I am very grateful to have but I also
want to be honest about the fact that
they are problems writing had always
been a safe and sane way for me to pour
out my obsessiveness and
of thinking but then suddenly it just
didn't provide that release anymore and
I realized you know that I I could stop
writing had become kind of miserable and
as I devoted more of my time to crash
course in the art assignment I realized
I have amazing work that I am so lucky
to do I miss writing but in the way you
missed someone you used to love and then
about a year ago I went back to it I
started writing something just for fun I
kept saying that to Sarah I'm just
writing this for fun I'm just writing
this because I think you'll like it but
of course those turn out to be pretty
good reasons to write still though this
is all kind of hard to talk about
because the usual arc of these
narratives is I had some failure but
then I plowed through and found greater
success than ever and I'm not at all
sure that's how this story will end I
don't know if I'll ever publish another
book and if I do I don't know whether
people will like it I know they probably
won't like it as much as they liked The
Fault in Our Stars I hope I finish the
book I'm working on I hope you like it
but I don't know but I think what
changed is that I got okay with not
knowing I used to be so certain I used
to have all these unshakable beliefs
about books and writing and how to be a
writer now my beliefs aren't just
shakable they're shaken that feels
uncomfortable but also productive I
think Hank I got to get back to writing
I'll see you on Friday